[Music]
in the previous video we learned what
refraction of light is refraction of
light is a transmission of light through
an object in which the light which is
incident obliquely bends at the boundary
of the two media we also said that the
bending of light in the medium is caused
by the change in its speed when light is
traveling from an optically rarer medium
to an optically denser medium its speed
decreases and it bends towards the
normal when the light is traveling from
an optically denser medium to an
optically rarer medium its speed
increases and it bends away from the
normal in the figure the case above is
from optically rarer to denser and the
case below is optically denser to rarer
but how does the change in speed result
in the change of direction of light I
did mention in my previous video that we
will understand this with the help of an
analogy for the next few minutes just
forget everything I told you about
anything related to light and just
concentrate on what I'm about to show
you here's a shopping cart which has
rotating wheels say I want to move this
shopping cart from the road to the grass
obviously I will push it or apply a
force on it assume that I will apply a
constant force throughout its journey
let us see what happens when I start to
move from concrete road to the grass
what did you notice as the wheels of the
cart entered the grass surface their
speed reduced the thought traveled at a
much lower speed on grass than on the
concrete road and the reason for slower
speed is rather obvious the grass offers
more resistance to the motion of the
cart than the concrete road here we can
consider the concrete road and grass as
two different media through which the
cart is moving
notice that the direction of the cart is
same in both the media we can think
about light in the same way something
similar happens when the light is
traveling perpendicular from an
optically rarer to an optically denser
medium the optically denser medium
offers resistance to the flow of light
and hence its speed reduces however its
direction does not change let's get back
to our cart example what will happen if
the cart enters the grassy surface at an
angle let us see that this is how it
would look now let's take the cart back
to the original position on the road and
we will look at the movement very slowly
as the cart approaches the grass surface
at an angle its right wheel will enter
first and as it enters here
it will slow down at that time the
adjacent wheel is still on the concrete
road and is hence moving with the same
original speed so the wheel on the grass
surface will move slower than the other
wheels for some time but let's focus on
the two front wheels both the wheels are
moving with different speeds as the
force applied is constant what this will
do is slightly turn the cart towards the
right the cart will change its direction
and continue moving in that direction
afterwards so the direction changed now
let me draw a normal to the surface now
we can see that the cart has taken a
turn towards the normal if the surface
wouldn't have changed the thought would
have continued to move in this direction
but because the surface changed the
direction of movement of the cart also
changed why am I telling you all this
it's because one can think of bending of
light in the same way when light is
obliquely incident on the surface of an
optically denser medium its speed
decreases and it bends towards the
normal part of the beam that enters
optical medium first slows down making
the entire beam to change the direction
towards the normal now let me ask you a
question how will the direction of light
change when it enters and optically
denser medium to an optically rarer
medium will it move towards or away from
the normal
to answer this question let's switch
back to the cart example this time the
cart is here on the grass and it's being
pushed towards the concrete patch what
will happen here this is how the
direction of the movement of the cart
will change why let's see the animation
slowly as the cart begins its movement
the right wheel will reach the boundary
first and after entering the concrete
patch its speed will change will it
increase or decrease it will increase
it's because the friction is lesser on
the concrete road so now this wheel will
move with greater speed but it's
adjacent companion is still on grass
moving at a slower speed so the change
in their relative speeds will turn the
cart towards this direction if I draw a
normal you can clearly see that it's
moving away from the normal in this case
if the surfaces were the same it would
have moved in this direction but as
they're different the direction as well
as the speed of the cart changes we can
apply the same analogy for the light
entering from an optically denser medium
to an optically rarer medium light can
propagate more easily in an optically
rarer medium than in an optically denser
medium in such a case its direction of
propagation will be away from the normal
in the refractive medium one last
question to which you will definitely
know the answer to what if the cart is
entering the concrete like this
perpendicular to the surface yes its
speed will increase but its direction
will not change so if the light is
entering an optically rarer medium in a
perpendicular manner then a speed will
increase but its direction will not
change in the next video we will talk
about a few examples of refraction
you